Please turn to Isaiah 52 and we're going to read verse 13 down to chapter 53 and verse
5.
So the reading there in your worship guide will stop just shy of where we're going to
read up to.
So if you've got a Bible, do have it open to Isaiah 52.
It says, Behold, my servant shall act wisely.
He shall be high and lifted up and shall be exalted.
As many were astonished at you, his appearance was so marred beyond human semblance and his
form beyond that of the children of mankind.
So shall he sprinkle many nations.
Kings shall shut their mouths because of him.
For that which has not been told them, they shall see.
And that which they have not heard, they understand.
Who has believed what he has heard from us?
And to whom has the arm of the Lord been revealed?
For he grew up before him like a young plant and like a root out of dry ground.
He had no form or majesty that we should look at him and no beauty that we should desire
him.
He was despised and rejected by men, a man of sorrows and acquainted with grief.
As one from whom men hide their faces, he was despised and we esteemed him not.
Surely he has borne our griefs and carried our sorrows.
Yet we esteemed him stricken, smitten by God and afflicted.
But he was pierced for our transgressions.
He was crushed for our iniquities.
Upon him was the chastisement that brought us peace.
And with his wounds we are healed.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, thank you so much for your word.
And Lord, we pray that by your spirit that you would open our eyes to see what you have
said here.
Lord, we've just read in your word that there are some who see and believe what your word
says.
And there are others who do not see.
And so I pray that you would open our eyes that we may see.
We may behold more of Jesus.
And that we would be changed as we look to him.
We pray this in his name.
Amen.
I don't know about you guys, but Christmas to me doesn't feel complete exactly until I've
watched Charlie Brown Christmas.
I don't know if you've got any go-to movies that you watched, but that's definitely mine.
And there comes a point in the Charlie Brown Christmas where they're going to have the
school play.
And Charlie Brown is given the tall task of going and getting the Christmas tree for
the school play.
And so he goes out and he gets it and he comes back.
And of course he comes back with this scrawny little tree.
And we have one at our house that Charlie Brown is holding.
And I was going to bring that this morning, but just imagine I'm holding that here.
And so he brings back this scrawny little tree.
And if you've seen it, you remember everybody's reaction.
Everybody's laughing and they're mocking him.
And he is absolutely distraught.
And so he ends up shouting out, is there anyone who knows what Christmas is all about?
This morning we're looking at a passage of Scripture that isn't often associated
with Christmas.
But it does tell us, in a sense, what it is all about.
And it does so by putting before us a little tree.
It's a picture of the advent or the coming of the Messiah, the Lord's servant.
We're told that he will appear.
Look with me once again at verse two in this way.
It says, for he grew up before him like a young plant and like a root out of dry
ground.
So for the next few moments here in the context of the wider passage that we just read, I want
to really focus on those first two verses and see what they tell us about Jesus' advent.
I grew up with the King James Version of the Bible.
And it began, chapter 53 began, who hath believed our report?
So that sticks in my mind.
So first of all, we're going to look at the prophet's report.
So what is he reporting?
And then we're going to look at the people's response.
All right?
So what is the message?
How do we respond to this message?
Okay.
So the prophet's report.
Who has believed what he has heard from us?
It's said here.
Or who has believed our report.
So what is this message that the prophet is proclaiming here?
Well, he uses two pictures to put it before us here at the start.
The two pictures are the Lord's arm and the young plant.
All right?
So you got those two pictures, the Lord's arm and the young plant.
So he says, who has believed what he has heard from us?
In verse one, and to whom has the arm of the Lord been revealed?
So what is he saying?
When he's saying the Lord's arm is revealed.
What is the Lord's arm?
Well, it's a picture of strength.
I thought about wearing a short sleeve t-shirt this morning so I could give you a picture.
But I thought, I'll spare you.
I'm sure you get the idea.
But if you look in Isaiah chapter 40 in verse 10, you see the arm.
The arm of the Lord being spoken of there as him ruling in mind.
Right?
So it's a picture of God's greatness, his power.
It's a picture of strength.
It's also a picture of salvation.
The first time it's mentioned in scripture is in Exodus chapter six and verse six.
It's a reference to God redeeming his people from Egypt by his strong arm.
And Isaiah is picking up this language of redemption here when he's talking about the Lord's
arm being revealed here.
So if you go back to chapter 52 in verse 10, he talks about the Lord's arm being revealed
in salvation.
It says, the Lord has bared his holy arm before the eyes of all the nations and all the ends
of the earth shall see the salvation of our God.
Okay?
So when it talks about the Lord's arm, it's talking about his power to save.
So to whom has it been revealed?
Who has seen the Lord's power to save is what is being said here.
And that power is going to be revealed to the nations.
So where is his saving power revealed?
What's revealed when a specific person comes into the world?
So it moves from talking about the Lord's arm to talking about him, this person who's
coming in the wider context is talking about the Lord's servant.
So who is the Lord's servant?
Who's this person who reveals God's saving power?
Well, that's when you then get to this second picture, this young plant.
We'll spend more time on that.
This unimpressive tree.
Four, he grew up before him like a young plant and like a root out of dry ground.
So you move from the picture of an arm now to a picture of a plant.
Now this is very two very different pictures, but they're both here next to each other.
So one's a picture of power and the other is surely a picture of weakness.
So you've got this juxtaposition of two images that contrast with each other,
but they're both referring to the same person.
So God's power is going to be revealed through someone who initially appears weak.
All right, so let's look at that picture of weakness, this little sapling.
Okay, so earlier in Isaiah, you read about judgment befalling Judah because of their sin.
So the Assyrians will attack and decimate Judah and will only leave a small remnant of people.
And they're described as an instrument in the hands of the Lord bringing about judgment.
It's almost as though the Lord has this instrument of the Assyrians in his hands like an axe
and this mighty tree is felled down to the stump.
That's the remnant that is there.
And not only that, that stump, this picture of this tree stump, it's burned with fire.
So looking at this stump that is Judah now is a picture of the terrible devastation and
judgment that had befallen them because of their sin and God's judgments.
It was a sad sight to look at.
It was a kind of a hopeless sight to look at this burned stump on the ground.
On our honeymoon, Julie and I traveled to the Lake District and we traveled to some areas around there too.
And one of the places we wanted to visit was Hadrian's Wall.
And I didn't fully recognize the significance of it at the time, but now looking back was like,
well, that is really significant.
It's this Roman wall that stretches 73 miles from one coast to the next.
And there's a very specific part of the wall that we wanted to go and visit.
And it was Sycamore Gap.
And it's this kind of dip that sort of takes place in the wall.
And right in the middle of the dip is this tree that's the Sycamore Gap tree.
And I thought, well, it's just a tree.
But actually it wasn't just any tree.
It was in the movie Robin Hood with Kevin Costner.
But not only that, it was the most probably the most iconic tree in the whole of England.
So for generations, families had gone on this walk at Hadrian's Wall and everybody would stop at this tree and have a picture.
And it was the most photographed tree in England.
So there's a lot of nostalgia attached to it.
Last year, 2023, you can imagine the sadness they hit the country when news came that somebody overnight
had gone and chopped the tree down.
Just an act of vandalism and had gone and decided they were going to fell this tree.
So it was sad to see that and to see that stump there.
And to just know we're never going to be able to take our kids that same spot to enjoy it in the same way.
And there's lots of folks who felt that way.
So it was a kind of sadness looking at that stump.
But then I remember a couple of months later, the sort of hopeful reports that were coming out on the BBC.
And that was that there were signs of life saplings were beginning to appear.
So it might take a long time, but the tree it seemed was going to begin to grow again as these new shoots began to emerge.
So here in the book of Isaiah, that the people of God are looking at this devastation that's befallen them.
They're looking at this stump.
But then they're given this message of hope.
All right. So judgment is going to be followed by salvation.
A shoot, little saplings are a little sapling is going to appear from this stump.
So Isaiah chapter 11 in verse one, here this, it says, there shall come forth a shoot from the stump of Jesse.
And a branch from his roots shall bear fruit.
It goes on to then describe that further in Isaiah 11.
So a shoot from the stump of Jesse.
So Jesse was King David's father.
And last week we saw the God had promised to send a king from this line to establish his kingdom.
So looking on the outward appearances, looking at the hopeless situation of Judah and the stump that was there, it seemed like
the kingdom would never be established.
The hope was lost.
But here the message is clear that there is life in that hopeless stump because a new David is coming
from the stump of Jesse.
A new David will be here.
And Isaiah 11 goes on to talk about how this little shoot that will grow up from the stump would grow into a glorious tree that would bear fruit.
And it would grow to be a signal for all nations.
And his coming, the coming of the King would result in the nations seeking after him and the end gathering of his people.
And in the end, it says, the knowledge of the Lord will cover the earth as the waters cover the sea.
So here's the idea here.
Although the people of God are looking at this hopeless situation, this smoldering stump, they could do so knowing that hope was not lost.
Salvation was coming.
God's Messiah would one day arrive and establish his glorious global kingdom.
And so now we get to that picture once again in Isaiah 53.
So that's what's going on here.
The King is coming, bringing salvation.
He's going to be exalted.
We read in chapter 52.
His reign is going to be glorious and global.
But that's not how it will appear at the start.
Imagine you're looking and you just see this burnt stump and this tiny little sampling.
His arrival, the arrival of the Messiah will appear unimpressive.
So it's kind of marking his smallness here to say that he is like this young plant.
So he arrives not like a mighty oak, but like a little sampling.
It's not the Rockefeller Christmas tree.
It's the Charlie Brown tree here.
It's small and vulnerable and unimpressive.
His arrival is and it's not just theoretically unimpressive.
He is literally vulnerable as he becomes a man takes on flesh.
This tender plant will grow up to experience immense suffering.
So you go through Isaiah 53 and you read about the suffering that's going to come when this vulnerable person comes in the world, who will then become the one who reigns overall.
Verse two of chapter 53, he has no form or majesty that we should look at him and no beauty that we should desire him.
So nobody's going to notice this little shoot.
He was despised and rejected by men, a man of sorrows and acquainted with grief, unimpressive.
Chapter 52 in verse 14 says that his appearance would be marred beyond recognition.
You go on even further.
It speaks of his death.
It talks about him being pierced.
He's going to be crushed.
He's going to be cut off from the land of the living.
So outwardly speaking, unimpressive.
And his arrival also be unpromising.
So notice back in verse two, it says he's like a root in dry ground.
Let's press into that picture roots draw from the soil in which they are planted without the proper nutrients.
They will not grow.
They will die.
So this root is planted in dry grounds.
Dry ground is a hopeless situation to be planted in.
Is this not exactly what we see in the life of Jesus?
He's the mighty savior.
He's the King of glory.
And yet when he came humanly speaking, he came in an unimpressive way and unpromising conditions.
His life was marked by smallness and suffering.
Think about his birth.
So his family was living in what was essentially a failed state, which is now under Roman occupation.
Think about the place where he was born.
He was born in Bethlehem.
Of course, there was prophecies about him being born in Bethlehem, the Messiah, when he comes.
But the prophecies emphasize the smallness of Bethlehem.
So Micah 5,2 says,
But you, O Bethlehem, who are too little to be among the clans of Judah, from you shall come forth the one for me of whom it is to be ruler, whose coming forth is from a old, from ancient days.
So it talks about it being little among the clans.
It's insignificant compared to other places.
Unimpressive, unpromising.
Of course, his birth was announced by angels.
But who was it announced to?
It was announced to shepherds.
People of a lowly profession.
How would they know that this, this baby was truly Christ the Lord?
Well, there was a sign given to them.
What was the sign?
It was going to be found in a manger, a feeding trough.
Pretty lowly, pretty unimpressive, pretty unpromising.
That theme carries on through his life.
He grows up in this insignificant place called Nazareth.
People said, you know, in John 1,
can anything come from Nazareth?
It's a bit like a podunk out of the way place.
And I was trying to think of places to refer to.
But I thought, who am I not going to offend
by referring to one of these places?
And then you say, well, at least maybe people
from his hometown could appreciate,
hey, we're from Nazareth, we're all in this together.
Well, Luke chapter four, you see that he's put down
by the people of Nazareth, people in his own hometown.
People said, isn't this Joseph's son?
And the idea there, that question people were asking,
if they were from Alabama, they'd be saying,
he's getting above his raising.
Is that kind of idea?
Like who does he think he is?
And in the end, they try to throw him off a cliff
to kill him.
That's how people in that small out of the way place
felt about him.
People wanted him dead.
And that's right the way throughout his ministry.
It's not just a one time occasion.
They tell him that they want him dead
because John 10 33, you being a man,
make yourself to be God.
So judging on appearances, people think,
well, he's just a man like everybody else.
Who does he think he is?
This guy from Nazareth, how could he be God?
Of course, some people put their hopes in him.
But they were thrown by what happened next
because of his death.
You see, he was pierced, he was crushed,
he was crucified, nailed to a tree.
To quote Isaiah 53, he was cut off
from the land of the living.
So how could this man who's being crucified?
I mean, if you're looking for a picture of God's power
and his mighty salvation,
it's gonna come into all the world.
You're not gonna be looking for somebody who's being
crucified.
And yet this is him.
This is the long awaited king.
Of course, his lifeless body is then taken
from the cross when he dies and laid into the tomb
like a root in dry ground, you might say.
It seems like hope is lost,
but there is more going on that meets the eye.
Now, a root cannot survive in dry ground,
but his life was not derived from this world.
He's not dependent on anything in this world for his life.
He is the very source of life itself.
The smallness and the sorrow and the suffering
he experienced in life didn't just happen to him.
It was something that he willingly embraced
when he came into the world.
He became a man that he might identify with us fully
in our suffering and even that he might die in our place
for our sins as a substitute we read about in Isaiah.
So let's read Isaiah 53 verses four to five again.
Surely he has borne our griefs and carried our sorrows.
Yet we esteemed him stricken, spitten by God and afflicted,
but he was pierced for our transgressions.
He was crushed for our iniquities.
Upon him was the chastisement that brought us peace
and with his wounds we are healed.
Let's read verse six.
It says, all we like sheep have gone astray.
We have turned everyone to his own way
and the Lord has laid on him the iniquity of us all.
So there we see that Jesus takes on our humanity,
our smallness, he humbled himself that he might suffer
and die the death that we deserved.
All right, so we've gone astray from God.
We deserve judgments because of our sin against him.
But Jesus became a man that he might be judged
as a man in our place.
So we were cut down in God's judgment.
Christ came that his life might be born in us,
that he might give us everlasting life.
As we know, his death is at the end of the story.
In Isaiah 53 even in verse 10 it says,
he shall see his offspring and he shall prolong his days.
So what's that all about?
So his life is cut short,
but the stump is at the end of the story.
His body is laid in the grave like a root in dry ground,
but three days later life springs from the tomb
as Jesus rises again to the power of an endless life.
So the work of salvation was accomplished.
I was reading about G. Campbell Morgan.
He spoke about a time he visited a graveyard in Italy
and as he's walking through the graveyard
he saw this huge tree and on either side of the tree
were these gravestones on either side of it
and he saw it and started thinking about it.
Well, what clearly happens is that there was a point
in time in which no doubt when somebody was buried there,
when the grave was dug rather,
and it seemed like an acorn had probably fallen down
into that and when the coffin is then put in there,
well then the acorn then springs up with life
and so there came a time when the tree grew
and then burst through the grave.
And so he talked about how that points
about how though it appeared small,
like within that acorn, within that smallness
was the power to conquer that grave later on.
So that's what we read here.
This young plant goes on to conquer the grave.
This is true not only in his own resurrection
but also in his offspring with the everlasting life
that is given to all who belong to him.
This healthy trees aren't just alive.
Healthy trees produce life as well.
So Jesus sees his offspring as a result of his great works.
As this tree grows, life is produced.
Fruit is born.
So Isaiah said in chapter 11,
fruit is born in all the earth.
And many years later, the apostle Paul
would go on to write to the church of Colossae
saying that the gospel is bearing fruit in all the earth.
Speaking of people coming to faith in Christ,
speaking of churches being started.
So as we look around here,
we are seeing the fruit of Christ's work.
So the life of Christ is planted
in the most unlikely of places.
He comes into the lives of the most unlikely of people.
It may not appear all that impressive or promising.
But if the living Christ is present, there is hope.
God himself is powerfully at work.
All right, so the question put before us here
in the text is, who has believed our report about him?
So how are we responding to this message about this Jesus?
So it's put forward as a question
because given how unimpressive things appear,
it's a message that people find hard to believe.
So that's why the question's being asked.
So there's essentially two responses.
One, there are those who reject Jesus.
And two, there are those who once rejected Jesus
but now believe.
Those are the two categories here in the passage.
So there's those who reject him.
So verse three says he's despised, literally dismissed
and rejected.
That's what we read in John one,
speaking about his coming into the world,
which we heard read last week.
It says he came into the world
but the world knew him not.
He came into his own but his own received him not.
In 1 Corinthians chapter one in verse 18,
as Paul is preaching the gospel,
he says the word of the cross is folly
to those who are perishing
but to us who are being saved, it is the power of God.
So people who reject the message of the cross
seeing it as weakness.
There are many today who hear the message of Christ
and his cross and they are not impressed.
They don't see him for who he truly is.
Then there are those who once rejected him but now believe.
Notice that Isaiah puts himself
in the category of rejecters.
So if you look at the end of verse three,
it says he was despised and we esteemed him not.
All right, so he's not just saying
those people out in the world, they rejected Jesus.
He's saying I'm part of that crowd too.
Like we did not see and embrace Jesus
for who he truly is.
He put himself in the category of the sinful people later on.
All we like sheep have gone astray.
All we, he's in the category too.
I don't know if you've ever seen the painting by Rembrandt,
the raising of the cross.
It's a beautiful painting
but it's a picture of Jesus being raised on the cross
and in the crowd of those who are raising the cross,
Rembrandt has a self portrait in there
because he's part of what's happening there.
It's his sin that's being dealt with too.
And so this is what Isaiah does here.
He is putting himself in the category of those
who rejected the Christ and refused his reign over their life.
So those who are once saved
aren't those who never like rejected Jesus
or are sinless or something like that.
Those who are saved, those who experienced
the arm of the Lord, his power to save
are those who confess their sinfulness,
the ways they've rejected Christ's reign over them.
And they believe that this Jesus was crucified for them.
So they admit that they've rejected him
and they receive him by faith.
So John one, which speaks about those who rejected Jesus
then goes on to say in John 1 12,
but as many as received him to them,
he gave the right to become the children of God,
to become his offspring, the fruit of the tree,
even those who believe on his name.
So God reveals his saving power
to those who put their faith in Christ.
So how should we respond when we hear the message?
Three quick things just as we close.
One, as we're looking at this little unimpressive tree,
the arrival of Jesus at Christmas,
it's called to own our own unimpressiveness.
Own our own unimpressiveness.
If Christ plants himself in unimpressive
and unpromising places, then surely we should say,
well, that's me, I'm happy to own my unimpressiveness,
my unpromisingness if Jesus is going to plant himself
in my life.
That's where he wants to be.
So that means admitting our sinfulness with Isaiah,
like we're in the category of those
who don't submit to his Lordship as we ought.
But it's also embracing our smallness,
embracing our weaknesses,
being honest about areas of struggle.
Christmas can be a time when we want to impress
if we have a Christmas party or something.
We want our house to be put together
and decorated just right
and the food has to be just right
and the presents have to be just perfect.
Are they gonna like what I've got
and then what are they gonna think or not think?
And we get bent out of shape,
especially if something's off
and that same desire to have everything right
in appearances can transfer into church life as well.
We can get fixated on wanting, I don't know,
numbers to be big or programs to be spectacular.
Well, the good news is
we don't have to worry about that right now.
So that's good.
But we can still want to appear to each other.
We all have it together, like everything's okay.
The packaging is just right.
The thing is Jesus doesn't turn up
once we get everything together.
He meets us right in the middle of our mess.
He already sees the things
that we would rather keep hidden away
unless knowing him is far better
than pretending like we have it all together.
We're gonna know his presence and work among us.
It's gonna come with owning our own unimpressiveness
that we might see his glorious saving,
life changing work in our midst together.
I love how Sam Albury changed the opening line
of, oh, come all you faithful,
perhaps to reflect this a bit more faithfully.
He said this, he said, oh, come all you faithless,
joyless and defeated.
Christmas is for the weary, for the messed up
and for the broken.
If your life isn't Instagrammable,
Christmas is for you.
So we come to a Christ who's ready to receive us.
We just sang earlier, a little town of Bethlehem.
It says we're Meek souls, not the proud souls,
not the impressive souls.
We're Meek souls will receive him
still the dear Christ enters in.
He plans himself like a root in dry ground.
So own our unimpressiveness,
but also believe the gospel.
That's the second way we should respond.
Believe the good news of Jesus.
The gospel, the good news of Jesus' death
and resurrection is the power of God
and the salvation for everyone who believes.
So scripture is given to us.
The book of Isaiah is given to us
that we might look beyond what our physical eyes
can see and see the work of God by faith.
We can see that no, the situation might look hopeless,
but through the eyes of faith, believing the gospel,
we can say, no, actually God is present
and he is at work whether I see it or not
and I can know that he will bring to completion
what he began.
I can believe the message of the gospel.
This changes how we see Jesus.
People, when we look through the eyes of faith,
people might ignore historical evidence
or brush him off as just a legend
or as an antiquated belief in the past.
By faith, we see him as the savior and king.
And it changes how we see our circumstances
when we look at them through the eyes of faith.
By faith, we see that our lives,
including the things we struggle with,
are just the sort of place where Christ plants himself
and where his glory is made known.
His power is made perfect in our weakness.
But not only that, so we own our own unimpressiveness,
but in that we believe the gospel
that Christ plants himself in our lives
and gives us his life.
And then when we believe the gospel
and we believe that God is at work
and he will bring to completion what he began,
we can then sing for joy, which we're gonna do here in a second.
On this third Sunday of Advent,
we began by thinking about joy.
That candle's still going, great.
But we see this here.
In Isaiah 52 and verse eight,
we see that the result of God's saving work
in the midst of his people is that they sing for joy.
Isaiah 53 is a very well-known chapter
in the Old Testament,
but perhaps not as well-known as how the next chapter starts.
After having seen Christ crucify,
Isaiah 54 begins with this word, sing.
That's how we respond to seeing Christ for who he truly is.
When Jesus instituted the Lord's supper
and right before he went to Gethsemane and the cross,
sometimes we can skip over the bit
that happens in the middle of that.
When they finished the supper,
he spoke about his body being broken,
his blood being poured out.
He knew what was about to befall him.
And yet before he went out,
what did he do with his disciples?
He sang with them.
It says they sang at him together.
And it was traditional to sing Psalm 114 to Psalm 118.
We don't know exactly if they sang all the verses of that
or if that's what they sang.
But at the time of Passover,
that's what the Lord's people sang.
So no doubt they sang that.
It's looking through Psalm 118
and it's a Psalm that says these words,
this is the day the Lord has made.
We will rejoice and be glad in it.
So whatever we are facing,
we can look to Christ
and all that we've been promised in him
and we can defiantly sing for joy.
Let's pray.
Lord, thank you so much
for your word and what you've spoken us about,
how you've pointed us to Jesus.
Lord, we thank you for how he humbled himself
and became a man and even humbled himself
to the point of death on a cross.
Lord, he was despised and rejected.
Lord, we thank you that he did that for us.
Lord, that he took our,
not only our humanity and our suffering,
but also he took on our sin
and died in our place on the cross.
Lord, we thank you for his triumphant resurrection
and Lord that he reigns forevermore.
Lord, we thank you for everything
that was accomplished through his death and resurrection.
Lord, we can know that one day
we will be with you forever through faith in him.
So Lord, I pray that whatever we are looking at today
and in the weeks ahead,
whether it appears to us to be wonderful and impressive
or small and insignificant,
Lord, I pray that we would not ultimately be looking
to those things for our hope, for our joy,
rather we would be looking to Jesus.
Lord, I pray that Christ would plant himself among us.
We would know his life in our midst
and we would rejoice in him.
Help us to do that even now we pray in Jesus' name.